welcome everyone i'm currently here in
the west of germany it is sunday evening
and tomorrow on monday we have a
workshop with a very important client of
ours a client of building radar the
company that i currently work for next
to me is leopold another colleague of
mine also at buildingraider and in this
video i decided to show you three things
three things we will do the first you
can just follow me along for the day see
how we conduct the client workshop
tomorrow thankfully client tomorrow
agreed that we can film also on site but
second i will also share some crucial
tips and tricks from my time here at
building radar but also before at
consulting on how to interacting with
clients and conducting workshops and
third i will also talk about some
general tips about being a manager in a
startup company interacting like that so
we just finished working on the document
for tomorrow it's already quite late so
we're about to go to bed by liverpool
thanks for joining me here
i do not only know leopold from work but
we also met already during university
when we started at our undergraduate
degree so i know that you had many other
opportunities as well you would also
have had the opportunity to go into
consulting into banking but you decided
to start a business start a startup
after university i trust that many of
you also would be interested to hear
what was your rationale for that
how did you think about that at that
time
yeah first of all heidi thank you for
having me and
really for me it all came down to
impact
starting
startup is really all about impact
during my time at google i really
noticed hey this is
really great here it's a nice tech
company it's a fast changing environment
but i just couldn't figure out for
myself what specific impact i had for
the company
and i realized
really the only way to have this impact
you want to have as an entrepreneur is
if you
start your own company that's why i
decided to start building weather and
our ambition is really to generate
something big here so we shot lots of
material at our workshop at custer and
we created a little clip a little mini
video to give an impression how these
workshops work what we do there and how
all those plays down so i will show you
this video now to give an impression of
how we do it at building radar
our mission at building radar is to help
companies in the construction industry
to increase their revenue with revenue
engineering many construction companies
we talk to tell us that all of their
functions have very detailed sales
processes with the exception of the
sales function
this is of course surprising because in
the end of the day sales pays for the
party
revenue engineering is the idea that the
sales process can be broken down in
small steps like a manufacturing process
and that then each individual step can
be trained and can be improved in a
systematic way
when we work together with new client of
ours the starting point is usually a
workshop week in the workshop week we
want to do three things first we want to
size the revenue potential of revenue
engineering of this new and innovative
way to conduct proactive sales for the
organization to do that we conduct
interviews in this workshop week with
different employees of the company
across hierarchy levels we also conduct
a conversation with the managerial
accounting team to collect all necessary
data and also conduct interviews with
the it department to understand all
dependencies
as a result of that we can come up with
a very clear picture what the revenue
potential for that individual company
with revenue engineering is over the
next two years
second we look at the organization and
capabilities of that client so from all
the interviews conversations and other
data sources that we have we assess the
current organization and understand to
what extent it is already fit for
revenue engineering or what the
potential gaps are that still need to be
closed by the management by the team in
order to be successful with revenue
engineering over the next two years
third we joined the developer roadmap
how a successful path towards revenue
engineering can look like here we
distinguish all the individual building
blocks that this organization needs to
have in place and still needs to come up
with in order to be successful we
develop a timeline how that could look
like and we also show different paths
with different partners out there how
the firm could actually get there
at the end of this workshop week we have
a full day with the senior leadership of
the company where we share our
preliminary results jointly co-create
some of the missing parts that still
need to be developed and then jointly
agree on how the next steps in the
journey for revenue engineering should
look like
today we conducted the last workshop day
with the senior leadership of custer
which is one of the leading general
contractors in germany we had a very
productive day in exchange and are very
much looking forward to the next steps
workshops are a key part of working and
consulting also many other professional
services firms and the key reason is
that usually you do not just want to sit
alone in the team room work on something
for several months and then at the end
of the project send over the results to
the clients because this will usually
not help to really create buy-in so
instead what you want to do is you want
to co-create results with your client
and surely workshops are a great way to
do that so let me share three tips from
my time here building radar but also
before in consulting at mckinsey on what
you can do to improve your workshop game
and the first is really to draw from
many many different data sources and
information sources that then you bring
to the workshop and what very few people
only do but what is often extremely
powerful is to talk to other employees
of the company because if you do that
what you achieve is that then when you
talk to the leaders to the decision
makers you can also tell them what their
employees told you and this clearly adds
to your credibility because the truth is
that in many especially of these larger
organizations the senior executives the
leaders they do not really know what on
an operational level all the people are
doing they often have a certain
preconception of that but it's not
always accurate what they think of what
is happening my second tip is about
creating the perception with the client
that the workshop was a success and that
some very very tangible results were
coming out of that because as a matter
of truth if you just sit there present
something maybe ask a couple of
questions ideally people will have
learned something but what most people
will like even more if the workshop
really created some tangible results
that they can then later use and then
build on and work with and what we like
to do both in consulting but also
building radar is to in the workshop
jointly develop things on the flip chart
come up with decisions come up with
results and then what we like to do is
after the workshop we create a document
with all the things we worked on all the
things we came up with and then we
distribute this document with all the
workshop participants and this makes it
very tangible very clear what you have
jointly developed what the results were
and this then often creates the
perception in your clients that yes the
workshop was not a waste of time but
highly productive and something came out
of that which surely was worth the time
and the money of all the people that
attended my third tip is about how to
make the workshop a memorable experience
and here my key insight that i learned
over time is that the more different
types of media the more different types
of formats that you use in the workshop
usually the better and the better will
be the memory that people have about it
and what i mean by that is the following
so if the whole workshop consists of you
standing in front of the crowd
presenting something asking questions
this is not necessarily a bad workshop
but what's often even better if then you
have parts of the workshop which are
conducted in front of the flip chart now
you're standing there you're jointly
developing something maybe you even have
another part where you have a whiteboard
or poster where you elaborate something
that then comes together written on the
poster maybe you have some sticky notes
that people can write on attached to the
poster of course you should not do this
only for the sake of doing this this
should always also just add value and
make sense in the overall context but i
would encourage you to really think
about that and just to add something on
top of just you standing in front of the
people and presenting something
so now i'm standing here outside of our
office here at building radar hope
today's video was insightful to get some
impressions at how we work and what it
is like and some tips on how to conduct
strong and successful workshops and as
always i want to say a big big thanks to
all the sponsors and members of the
channel you're really making a big
contribution thank you for that if you
took any value out of this video at all
please destroy the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
the channel to stay up to date on all
the content my name is heinrich i'm
releasing new videos every single
saturday so see you soon next week all
the best to you and bye